it's gonna be the Vikings at the 49ers
and some alarm yesterday for Vikings
fans who should be used to it because it
was last Friday that all of a sudden
Mike Hughes and McKenzie Alexander two
of their key defensive backs not
available for Sunday's game against the
Saints the Vikings have Stefon Diggs who
has missed practice on Tuesday and
Wednesday although they didn't really
practice on Tuesday with an illness and
Adam feel and apparently went down
yesterday in practice with an ankle
injury
the Vikings may have a problem now
Zimmer Mike Zimmer the coach of the team
apparently said feeling is fine but I
wouldn't expect him to say anything but
that
and with Diggs you know I wonder whether
this is a repeat of what we saw from
Diggs after that Bears game in week four
when he was miffed about his lack of
involvement because it was clear on
Sunday he was miffed about his lack of
involvement in the game against the
Saints yeah well I would imagine he's
pretty happy at this point right now I
mean come on he had a huge football
season he was one of the focal points of
their offense statistically did good I
don't think he's pulling any shenanigans
here he's you know the flu is everywhere
I need coach team we've seen over the
last two or three weeks they're kind of
all dealing with it so but either way if
they did not have these two guys that
would be a huge blow to their football
team certainly I mean hey the big thing
about this game is can Dalvin cook run
the football okay once he debt he does
run the football in the way San
Francisco plays they give you a lot of
one-on-one opportunities outside against
the keel the weatherspoon or Richard
Sherman so to me one of the key factors
of the game will be Ken Diggs and feel
and just kind of win their one-on-one
matchups outside and Cousins put the
ball in a good spot I think that could
be a huge thing for the Vikings offense
and team in general yeah and look I mean
Phelan was phenomenal against the Saints
seven catches 129 yards overcoming that
early fumble that could have caused the
whole game to go off the rails great
catch for the ages right over the
shoulder making that that reception
setting up the final touchdown they need
feel and they need digs they don't have
much depth behind them they have Kyle
Rudolph and herb Smith junior at tight
end I still think what Dalvin cook in
Alexander Madison do in the running game
is going to be the key because frankly
they got
guys who can get open if the 49ers
defense is so focused on trying to
figure out how they're going to stop
Dalvin cook in Alexander Madison that
those guys are gonna pop and it's just a
question of them catching the pass when
it comes their way
but something to definitely watch
because if Thielen is injured yes that's
gonna because we saw I mean the offense
didn't go completely in a shell during
the weeks that Phelan was out but to
have everybody back and healthy for the
first time against the Saints we saw
what the offense can be yeah exactly
right it's just another weapon it's hard
to hang your hat on oh who would they go
into here and when we do play man-to-man
or leave our corners in those situations
hey there's just a 50% greater chance
with both of them are on the field that
yeah Kirk Cousins one of them's going to
be open one of them's going to beat
their guy man-to-man and you know Mike
like you said yeah I'm no dummy you're
no dummy we know the key to the
Minnesota Vikings is Dalvin cook in the
running game but I also sit there go hey
San Francisco knows that too and D
Ford's gonna be back and Quan Alexander
it sounds like he's gonna be back and
they're gonna be healthy and fresh and
all week Robert Sala is gonna be beaten
into their brain we gotta stop the run
game we got to stop the run game we got
to stop the run game they're gonna be
like rabid dogs as far as that's
concerned so to me that's where one of
those things I would watch out early in
the game where Minnesota might play
through the pass a little at first just
to calm down that front seven oh let me
throw it out here to feeling maybe he
can make Richard Sherman miss make a
move get 15 20 yards you know that might
have to be the plan of attack because I
think that defense will be honed in on
number 33 very very keenly and you make
a good point because when the Vikings
won the toss against the Saints they
didn't elect to defer they wanted the
ball and there's a mentality from Mike
Zimmer that we're gonna go for it that
the slogan for the Vikings in this
playoff run is go get it and Mike Zimmer
has taken that literally and there is a
level of aggressiveness from the Vikings
that we typically haven't seen and
that's one of the benefits of being the
six seed because we're near the sixth
seed you're supposed to lose and with
each game you win hey we're just on
house money at this point what
supposed to lose and that mentality if
we're just gonna go get it and and in a
game like this on Saturday where all the
pressures on the 49ers they're the one
seed they're the team that's the week
off they're the team that has everything
to lose if you come out early and and
you know I compare it to a heavyweight
championship where the champ is a big
favorite and he gets caught by Buster
Douglas early with a lucky punch and put
on his but it changes everything then
the next thing you know you're in a
fight that you weren't supposed to be in
yeah that's exactly right and you know
hey there's a lot of different ways they
can attack this but this defense in San
Francisco is real it's healthy it was
reeling a little bit at the end of the
year so will it regain a little bit more
of the form we saw in November in
October and September when they were
dominant because in December they
statistically were one of the worst
defenses in the NFL and you know of
course injuries did play a big part of
that I get it but you're right Mike I
mean I think Zimmer and Kirk Cousins
have a little bit of a they realize we
got to push the envelope a little bit
more on the offensive side of the ball
to come out of the NFC and I think they
will try to be aggressive and one of the
things like I banged on the table for
somebody to run at the New England
Patriots because they were small upfront
if there's one thing I've said all year
about the 49ers that I think too is just
you can attack these corners we saw a
killer Witherspoon get benched at the
end of the Seattle game right in week 17
and Richard Sherman I think has some
flaws too I mean to me that would be one
of the areas I would really want to
attack feeling digs Cousins let's not
make this complicated let's just work
these guys on the outside and see if we
can make some plays and Kirk Cousins
entering the game with a little boost of
confidence that came from getting his
first postseason victory with a couple
of big deals in overtime in New Orleans
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports